ganz großes thema heute bei uns auch im
blatt heute in einem seniorenheim in
leverkusen starben 15 menschen nach der
impfung und zwar an dem britischen an
der britischen krone mutation wie kann
das sein wie es denn der schutz dieser
impfung also man weiß nicht genau wann
die leute sich zieht sich in sich
infiziert haben und ich sag mal kannst
du doch man kann ja nicht
es gibt leute die sterben vor der
impfung aber man kann nicht mit der
impfung haben also der schutz ist gut
der wirkt auch wir müssen nur wissen
viele leute sind schon vorher infiziert
dann kommt dann kommt das kommt das team
rein und dann stirbt man dann natürlich
alles spektakuläre meldung muss man
genau hingucken und das nachgewiesene
impfschutz ist da und die erste impfung
gibt einen impfschutz von etwa 50 bis 60
prozent und dann kommt die zweite
impfung das ist eine so genannte auf
besserung eine muster und dann hat man
den vollen impfschutz aber das kann
immer passieren dass leute obwohl sie
gerade geimpft sind die impfung wirkt ja
auch erst nach wenigen tagen also die
wirklich sofort sondern erst nach der
auch erst nach einigen tagen das kann
immer vorkommen so dramatisch und so
traurig wie diese einzeln meldung ist
das kann passieren und wir wissen ja
alle man braucht auch den zweiten peaks
deshalb spricht ja dann leider doch
vielleicht einiges dafür den lock down
zu verlängern oder wie kriegen wir
kommunen griff das große problem ist ja
nicht dass sie momentan so exorbitant
hohe zahlen haben die zahlen gehen ja
glücklicherweise runter wir haben in
deutschland insgesamt incidents liegt
unter 100 also die ist nicht mehr so
dramatisch das problem sind die
mutationen die aus südafrika aus
brasilien und und aus großbritannien
kommt die hand das große problem die
machen angst denn die sind viel viel
ansteckender ist das sehen wir jetzt
auch in diesem heim 15 leute das geht
wirklich
durch diese mutter durch diese
mutationen die einfach viel schneller
anstecken mehr anstecken mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren